Let's see if we can divide
5.005 by-- let's divide it by 7,
and see what we get.
So we can rewrite this
as 5.005 divided by 7.
And the key here is to
keep track of the decimal.
But other than
that, you're really
treating it like a traditional
long division problem.
So you want to put
the decimal, it's
to the right of the ones place.
So it's right over there.
I just put the decimal
right above the decimal.
And now we would
treat it just like
a traditional long
division problem.
So how many times
does 7 go into 5?
Well, it goes into
5 zero times, and we
could write 0 times 7 is 0.
Actually, let's do
that, just to show
that it works to kind of do the
process all the way through.
0 times 7 is 0.
You subtract, you get 5.
So you get this 5
right over here.
So you get 5, and then we
can bring down another 0.
We bring down this
0 right over here.
So now we ask ourselves, how
many times does 7 go into 50?
Well, 7 times 7 is 49, so
it's going to go seven times.
7 times 7, 49.
Subtract, you get 1.
And now we can
bring down this 0.
Let's do that.
We bring down that 0.
7 goes into 10 one time.
1 times 7 is 7.
Subtract, get a 3.
And now finally, we
can bring down this 5.
We can bring down the 5.
And we ask ourselves, how
many times does 7 go into 35?
Well, 5 times 7 is 35.
This goes 5 times.
5 times 7 is 35.
Subtract, and we are done.
We have divided it completely.
And so 5.005 divided
by 7 is equal to 0.715.